just horrible yeah it was just dark and
dingy i think we had to rip up the whole
floor because it had damp coming up
through it yeah um and that's seen as a
major structural issue and so we
literally ripped out the whole floor out
yeah and then relayed it correctly
because i'm using a lot of developments
you've done lots of different projects
in the past but when you see a project
and it's got structural issues there's
problems it's cash only yeah it's
unmortgageable
what do you what do you think when you
see
properties that we want to go and see
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and everywhere i go
in the country i've got students i've
got academy members killing it in
property right now i'm standing in
coventry a really expensive nice part of
coventry and the sun is shining and this
house was bought by one of my students
hannah and this house it looks like an
average house but this is the thing she
only ended up leaving 15 grand into this
deal so it's basically a house for 15
grand and she's going to get a massive
amount of rent via serviced
accommodation so i thought i'd show you
around the house she can give you a tour
uh so that you can do the same time it's
the kind of thing too because if you're
trying to structure properties the
normal way buy to let leaving deposits
in renting out to normal tenants it's
the old school way this is the new
school way so let's go
hannah
come on in hello
this is hannah bowden you are killing it
right now congratulations on the
purchase thank you we have a little
walkthrough coming in guys amazing
amazing
oh nice it's got that new that new smell
yes like a new build
great so when did you buy this house we
bought it um six months ago six months
ago night and you've done the work like
you've literally done everything yep
pretty much and you've accepted you've
extended this yep this is an extension
that was stood in right now so we've
done this under permitted development
rights permitted and what does
permission development so basically we
have a right to extend to a certain
amount of meterage without getting
planning permission right so you bought
the house you bought it so cheap yep
you've done it up beautifully you've
extended it yep what um if we step
outside let's have a look out the nice
new extension you've done this so fast
as well yes six months six months for
the refurb what's your thing what have
you had to do to the house what was
wrong with it when you got it so
basically we had to start off by
stripping it back to brick and we had to
pull out the whole of the ground floor
because it had structural issues on the
floor um and uh then basically rebuild
it and put this extension on because
we're ripping out the floor we thought
may as well do the extension do it under
permitted development rights as far as
we could yeah and
go from there really so how much money
hannah in total including the structural
issues the full refurb everything how
much money have you had to spend on this
entire project 60k 60k yep
60k in six months that's good because i
think the thing is what makes pro
projects profitable is being able to do
them in budget in time scale yep um what
was it that caught your eye about this
house because there's a lot of houses on
the market yeah what was it that made
you think this is the one well it's the
fact that we could negotiate on the
price because of the structural issues
and it was cash buyers only yeah yeah
and when you see a project because i
know you're using a lot of developments
you've done lots of different projects
in the past but when you see a project
and it's got structural issues there's
problems it's cash only yeah it's
unmortgageable
what do you what do you think when you
see
probably the ones that we want to go and
see right why is that because we know we
can finance it um not just through our
own cash but through um the bank's cash
through bridging yeah and also if
there's a property that's unmortgageable
first-time buyers can't touch it no buy
to let landlords can't touch it like 95
of buyers need a mortgage yeah but
you're going in going i'm actually cash
oh by the way it's not my cash i'm
getting a bridging loan exactly so you
bought this for how much 170. 170. nice
well i love it and i love i think one of
the most important rooms is the kitchen
and you know you've by extending it
you've created a beautiful kitchen your
kitchen dining area
it had a really pokey kitchen a tiny
kitchen beforehand you've got this nice
spacious kitchen diner yes and we're
going to put a little seating area here
as well yeah and a tv on the wall so
everyone could be all together and yeah
it was just horrible yeah it was just
dark and dingy talk to me about the
floor what the problem was and what
you've done so basically we had to rip
up the whole floor because it had um a
damp coming up through it yeah um and
that's seen as a major structural issue
and so we literally ripped out the whole
floor out yeah and then relayed it
correctly to the legs and then were
there other structural bombs was it just
this disruption and there was a few
issues where we had to tie in the
outside walls back into the house and
things like that and internal walls were
kind of floating a little bit and not
sat on the foundations properly so we
corrected absolutely everything and most
people wouldn't even know where to start
with that would then most people would
not know how much it costs they wouldn't
they might think it's going to cost them
60 grand just for the structural issues
yeah but you've literally with 60 grand
you've extended the property you've
refurbed the whole place yep um right
now i mean i've got to ask what's with
the mattress in the kitchen what's going
on today so we are furnishing it today
so that's going to go into the front
room which we can show you um and yeah
so we're trying to get everything
together so we can get it rented out on
our service accommodation and why are
you renting out not just to a family
because we can make far more money yeah
how do you know it'll rent out because
i've got a
similar property three bed four bed
property across the other side of the
city that i rent out on airbnb really
works really well and it works really
well nice all right show us the rooms
then love it though
[Music]
so with this property then when you're
renting out a service accommodation like
what type of people will be staying here
and how do you make sure that the place
doesn't get trashed so the people that
i'm wanting to target are contractors
and also people who are working at the
hospital because we're within a mile of
the hospital which is a massive
university hospital and they get a lot
of doctors and nurses who come in just
for specific time periods right who
either rent houses or they just look for
airbnb because when people think of
service accommodation a lot of people
think tourists
probably not going to go on holiday in
coventry no
right barbados or coventry you know so
what are your most common types of
guests with your property that you've
got on the other side of the street so
during the week i get contractors and
they tend to be people like road workers
they're doing particular projects within
the city and they just want somewhere
really close by and that they can stay
out during the week and then at the
weekends i do actually fill it up with
people who are visiting friends in the
city so not
touristy but they're visiting people
that they know people are just traveling
or yeah but like like the kind of people
that will stay in hotels normally yeah
and also i've had quite a lot of people
who are traveling up north and use this
as a respite in midway in their journey
or vice versa south to north yeah as
well and you can't just say i'm going to
put it on airbnb and sit back and you
need to understand how to run the
business out of the system of your
business who your market's going to be
so who who's the market in this area how
do you market the property so basically
at first i had it so you could book just
one night out for any time during the
week um but the problem that i found is
that that somebody would book it for
maybe a wednesday or thursday night
because they were going on a training
course but then i won't get anybody else
for the rest of the week yeah um until
weekend and i found that then i couldn't
get my contractors who tend to be monday
to thursday or monday to friday right
which are my bigger block bookings and
more money how much do you anticipate
this will went out for per month what do
you think the turnover will be every
month i would anticipate um between two
and a half and three thousand and if you
did it as a family letter it would be
what a grand 1100 we can get for it 1100
makes sense service accommodation all
the way it's tax efficient as well yep
you've got you've got a higher
higher cash flow yeah and also i found
service accommodation that the property
is maintained better because i've got
cleaners coming in how do you find your
cleaners and what does what do the
cleaners do i've got a really great set
of people that i've managed to find um
and they basically come in and do not
just the cleaning they reset the
property they make sure that everything
nothing's broken
and they also do all my laundry which is
amazing so i don't have to touch
anything yeah um and yeah they basically
look after it they're almost like
property
many property managers yeah and you've
got key safe outside yes systemized yeah
like it really nice i like the flooring
that you've gone with as well and i can
imagine when this is furnished finished
you know you've got it really nice
staged properly it's gonna just look
amazing good size
yeah great
so
[Music]
[Music]
i can smell the fresh paint yeah
nice very bright and airy yeah it's
quite big rooms aren't there yeah nice
really nice size yeah and these are
going to not be rented out room by room
right no whole house yeah you have to
unless you've got ensuites and stuff in
your rooms you just got to do the whole
just gets a bit messy yeah exactly so
with your
managing of one refurb alone can be
quite stressful yeah you've literally
you've built houses from scratch yes
you've got rent to rent yeah you're on
the academy yeah you're um you got four
kids yep four how do you find the time i
mean when we first met i think when you
came to your
academy trial day so to speak you had a
six day old baby yeah and i was just
like what
like how do you manage to do all of this
and have four kids well we just decided
last year when um we had joshua that
something needed to change after having
three children
um previously i
felt like i wasted my maternity my time
off work whereas this time we both
decided right we need to do something
and we need to change um
change the outcome course of our
life really right
and we are good at property we like
property and so we just wanted to extend
our your partner's a builder he's a
builder she's really helpful yeah so
he's been building a game for like over
20 years yeah yeah yeah and how how
important do you think it is as well
when you've got obviously you've got a
builder as a partner which is really
really helpful but like under having not
just a builder but a team of finance
sources like how important is having a
good team and environment in doing what
you're doing it's it's absolutely key
and then i found an amazing mortgage
broker who who gets what we're trying to
do
um because he does it himself so he's he
does renovations he does projects so he
understands what i'm looking for when i
go to him and go right i've got this i
need some finance for it and he
understands how to structure it yes
that's really really important yeah
having the right team around you and
stuff and time management like four kids
that's so demanding how do you how do
you manage to
do do this business and have four kids
it isn't
um easy i'm not gonna lie um but also we
we have a great support network so i've
got parents around who can help with the
kids they can go and do school runs
and we've got um al's mum who's local to
this property um so she's around quite a
bit and can help out and that's really
key having a support network not just a
um
a team of network of people who can help
you do the actual
physical side it's the support side yeah
which is really really key yeah that's
great love it really nice property so
what would you say hannah does somebody
that maybe is wanting to do projects
like this
but doesn't have a partner who's a
builder doesn't have a support network
of people that can babysit the kids yeah
like what would you what would you say
to someone that was saying because
obviously you've seen
hundreds of people with every different
excuse yep what would your advice be to
someone that wants to get in this game
but necessarily feels like they haven't
got that support
well on like from the building side of
things go and network and find somebody
and go and find a team
because there are people out there who
are willing to help um and then on the
support side
you know yes we have all the support but
a lot of times the kids come with us the
kids have grown up around building work
and
because we're trying to teach them and
show them what we're doing because
ultimately what we're doing is for them
um so we we use it as a teaching
exercise for the kids that's great yeah
and what was the moment when you
realized because i know you've been
doing property for many years yeah when
did you decide to go all in and start
doing like rent to rents and service
accommodation like when did you yeah
when did you realize actually you know
what this is a viable business and we
wanted to do this properly so
a tipping point was a couple of years
ago we built our own house that we lived
in and
we lived in it for a few years and we
decided to sell up
that property and take the money and do
something with it and we always knew
that property was something that we
wanted to do
um i i went on a dfe from yours in 2019
following that we actually um bought a
piece of land and built two houses
um and then then last year we were like
we have got to do something now to we've
got to kind of up our game and do
something more and so we revisited you
guys and came to the discovery today
joined the academy and then learnt more
about the service accommodation rent to
rent
um and also about um more of like
financing and restructuring yeah i think
because this has happened so fast like
the buyer refurbishment even this even
this property the fact that you bought
in you'll be financing it just within
six months yes what more what mortgage
lender are you using uh shaw brooke shaw
brook bank yes and we're actually
remortgaging with them right so you
bought it with them and was it like a
bridge to let
no just a bridging loan yeah and then
they've got the best product
right to turn it into a service
accommodation
you need your correct mortgage what's
your what's your strongest reason for
doing this business it's the kids 100
the kids because we want to be able to
pass something on to them
um you know not necessarily straight
away but you know further down the line
and build a business and an empire we
always call it um that they can be proud
of and they can take on and do
themselves as well yeah that's amazing
so you've got one last bedroom yep what
are you gonna do then with this smallest
bedroom what are you gonna what are you
gonna put inside
it's um just a single bed okay so you're
gonna put a bed in here as well yeah
just single bed and then there'll just
be a chest of drawers so this could be
like maybe a cop room or something as
well maybe a kid's a kid's room or an
adult if it's just a single bed single
bed so it'll be big enough for an
yeah yeah that's cool oh no i really
like it and you've done read on the
driveway by the looks of things yeah so
basically it it was just a garden and we
literally just had the drop curb done
this week no i should definitely get
planning for that uh yes
so we've redone the upstairs toilet but
we've also put in a downstairs toilet
and shower room
right for the purpose of um service
accommodation because what we've learned
from our other one across the city is
that that's only got one bathroom yeah
and then you've got contractors four
different contractors in yeah it's a bit
nicer to have two yeah people get
showered and get ready yeah different
times amazing great so you've made a
profit then on this one deal of how much
sixty thousand sixty thousand profit and
you'll be renting out for probably about
two and a half three on service
accommodation how much cash flow in your
pocket do you think this will leave you
every month um around a thousand pounds
wow yeah that's incredible oh well thank
you so much for letting us look around
okay what would be your
best piece of advice from all the deals
that you've done to the audience
watching who are wanting to get started
in property
increase your knowledge and just go for
it it's the best piece of advice yeah
that's so true and you know i always say
invest a little bit in yourself before a
load of money and property yep and also
taking action because it's so easy isn't
it to be so pessimistic we're talking
about this on the figures on this you
can it's important to know when to walk
away from a deal if the deal doesn't
start yeah but some people are so
pessimistic about what if it goes wrong
what if this happens it's like well what
happens if
you get fired or get hit by a bus if
someone's got to be a little bit
optimistic and take action yeah which is
what you've done but this has certainly
paid off yeah
what's next for you hannah
we're looking at our next project which
possibly some flats
yep well i'm sure there'll be an update
soon you're going to see hannah's full
story on winners on a wednesday later on
in the year is that right yes absolutely
and uh listen guys if you enjoy the
channel don't forget hit the like button
subscribe if you want to see more videos
like this there's a whole playlist up
here and i look forward to seeing you
guys next time
[Music]
you